dont les questions essentielles autour
du coronavirus et du déconfinement de
nombreux spécialistes s'accordaient
jusque là à dire que l'immunité
collective était une option car selon
eux une fois que les personnes ont
attrapé le coronavirus ils sont
immunisés
en clair ils ne peuvent donc plus la
trappe et ni le transmettre une
information relayée à longueur de
journée sur les plateaux de télévision
du monde entier sauf que voilà hier un
scientifique a remis en cause cette
certitude sur l'immunité le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy a été auditionné dans la
matinée par le sénat pour faire un point
sur la situation sanitaire est dans son
discours l'homme de science a fait une
révélation pour le moins surprenante
après avoir qualifié le virus de
vacheries il a expliqué on est même en
train de se poser la question si
quelqu'un qui attrapent locaux vides 19
et qui est positif est véritablement si
protégés que ça une déclaration choc qui
fait écho aux recherches de plusieurs
scientifiques sud coréen qui auraient
observé il ya quelques jours une
résurgence du virus chez des personnes
guéries selon le directeur général de la
santé jérôme salomon ce virus a émergé
il ya trois mois donc nous n'avons pas
encore beaucoup de recul sur son
évolution et sur la réponse de l'homme à
l'infection mais alors peut-on attrapé
le virus une deuxième fois
alors avant d'avoir avant d'avoir la
réponse
enfin les éléments de réponse de jimmy
mohamed est ce que vous vous craignez
que l'on puisse attraper le virus
une deuxième fois c'est vrai que mine de
rien pour moi je trouve que c'est la
question mine de rien est essentielle
on est d'accord jean-michel barils et
surtout la question est posée est ce
qu'on peut la voir une première fois
fait que ce soit pas grave et de la 2è
la raison sont très graves et très bonne
question
très bonne question aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que tu peux faire voilà est-ce
qu'on peut se poser la question est là
dessus sophie c'est parce qu'on nous
avait dit au départ en fait moi ce que
j'avais compris c'est à dire que la
primo-infection c'est à dire la première
fois qu'on contracte le virus c'est la
plus virulente
si j'ai bien écouté jimmy c'est ce qu'il
avait dit à l'époque je me suis au tout
début et après ce que j'ai aussi entendu
c'est que effectivement plus ça a été
virulent plus effectivement on va être
immunisés dans le temps d'accord mais
j'ai cru comprendre donc effectivement
déjà beau bonjour au jimmy'z quand on te
voir mais effectivement oui c'est une
vraie vraie vraie vraie vraie question
d'un partage scène jean-michel c'est
qu'effectivement moi ce que j'ai entendu
c'est la question que jamais posée à
jean michel six mille pardons
c'est que j'ai entendu que brosse à
dents la deuxième bac qui est l'arrivée
la seule question qu'on se pose c'est
quelle bête sa force mais qu'en revanche
qu'il y ait une deuxième vague
c'est aujourd'hui une certitude voilà ce
qu'on veut comme l'entend aussi donc
effectivement si jamais on l'a eu
est ce qu'on peut avoir une deuxième
fois que cette deuxième vague qui
forcément arriver paraît-il aux nations
du virus rené brillet moi je me recule
pas que je suis parisien comme paris
mais j'ai cru comprendre de la même
chose que sophie j'avais vu un talent
dans sa vie me dis mais pas ce que jimmy
merci d'être là et bravo heureux des
jimmy bosch et riz alors je questions
vraiment qui se pose et on veut
absolument
voilà on veut pas tomber tes mais si tu
as des éléments de réponse moi je suis
arrivé de question dispose très bonnes
questions dures michel mr déjà est-ce
que bah déjà première la question c'est
est ce qu'on peut attraper le virus
plusieurs fois maintenant voilà que des
éléments de réponse
alors comme vous le savez le professeur
jean françois delfraissy déprécie pardon
qui est le président du conseil
scientifique se pose la question c'est
lui qui conseille emmanuel macron on a
aussi mike ryan qui est le directeur du
programme d'urgence de l' oms qui se
posent la question donc je vais pas vous
mentir jim webb a dit l'ansés pas
forcément plus que ces éminents experts
ce qui peut être un peu embêtant c'est
que dans les semaines précédentes si on
se remémore un peu ce qui s'est passé on
nous a asséné 11 à 10 ne vous inquiétez
pas vous l'avez une fois vous êtes
tranquille vous est immunisé et là on
est en train de faire un petit peu
marche arrière et c'est peut-être ce
double discours qui commence peut-être à
gaz un les français puisque on dit que
désormais et on constate moi je le vois
aussi que des gens qui ont attrapé le
courant n'avait reçu première fois
certains on ne sait pas quel pourcentage
exactement deux à trois semaines après
se remettent à faire un syndrome grippal
un peu étonnant moins sévère et l'idée
de l'immunité peut tenir quand même un
petit peu puisque lorsque vous découvrez
le coronavirus pour la première fois que
votre corps ne connais absolument pas
cette infection et vous tombez malade
plus ou moins gravement
mais une fois que vous avez vous êtes
guéri vous avez créé des anticorps et on
peut quand même penser que ces anticorps
par mes traits de guérir en cas de
deuxième infections c'est ce que olivier
ferrand a avancé hier ou avant-hier en
revanche on sait absolument pas si les
anticorps que vous avez seront durables
dans le temps un élément de réponse lors
d'un autre couronne à virus dans les
années 2000 on s'intéressait à
l'immunité des gens ils en sont rendus
compte qu'ils avaient des anticorps qui
les protègent et pendant deux à trois
ans ce qui veut donc dire que nous ne
sommes pas sûrs d'une limite et durable
et nous mêmes on n'est même pas sûr que
le virus qu'on a en soi
peut-être va juste réactivée est ce que
c'est juste le fait que comme l'herpès
vous allez faire des récurrences on ans
est
rien et pour répondre à la question de
mathieu l'histoire de la deuxième vague
alors amis il y aura une deuxième vague
d'épidémie ça semble plutôt évident
puisque pour qu'une épidémie
disparaissent il faut une des deux
conditions soit que nous ayons avax ans
c'est pas le cas et à mon avis on aura
pas avant très longtemps ou que 60 % de
la population soit immunisée on ensemble
très très très très loin
ce qui veut donc dire qu'au moment du
décompte final nous allons avoir des cas
il va falloir apprendre certainement à
vivre avec le virus pendant de
nombreuses semaines voire nombreux mois
merci ça qui nous a répondu il y aurait
pu y avoir une deuxième fois c'est oui
auditeurs jédir pour atteindre perdu
vous pouvez pas aller donner des leçons
d'humilité ati mais ça y est c'est
reparti c'est parti sur ce qu'il est
depuis qu'il a dit du mal de du
professeur how i met sur sa tête
bah voilà il est illégal à l'énergie
craignez vous que l'on puisse attraper
le cros navire-usine ce convoi oui et
apparemment c'est oui judy me a priori
la deuxième fois qu'on rattrape c'est
moins grave faits semblent en tout cas
nous ce qu'on a observés en moins
sévères mais une note études en chine
avaient montré que sur 175 malades
l'ensemble des balades avec des cra en
après l'infection avait développé des
anticorps ne sais absolument pas si
c'est dû au fait que ces malades en fait
il n'était pas guérie encore est-ce que
c'était des faux positifs ya énormément
de doutes même si on pense que si tout
le monde faisait 2 à 3 fois qu un virus
nous aurions une épidémie d'une plus
grande ampleur donc peut-être que ça
concernera une petite partie de la
population
on n'en sait strictement rien mais
encore une fois falloir patienter toi
t'as déjà vu des cas de personnes qui
avaient des deux fois qu'ils ont eu deux
fois ou par willy autour de moi des
syndromes et d animer de ça aussi qui
était tombé malade et deux à trois
semaines à faire recommencer à faire de
l'assiette des patients que je suis en
train de suivre en ce moment à qui j'ai
fait faire le test pour savoir si
effectivement c'est du corona virus et
même à l'hôpital certains comparent le
rapport que des malades qui ont une
première fois la couronne à mios ont eu
un deuxième test positif on sait
absolument pas où est ce combat est ce
que c'est des erreurs de laboratoires
parce que les tests ne sont pas
forcément hyper performant on peut avoir
un test qui est négatif alors que vous
avez la maladie et à linverse vous
pouvez avoir un test positif et le test
ne peut se tromper
donc est ce que ces espèces qui sont pas
très fiables et ce qu'on met plus de
temps à guérir
est ce une réponse immunitaire c'est un
peu compliqué et c'est vrai que c'est un
peu nourrir
c'est à mon avis mais je pensais puisque
on pensait qu'une fois qu'on l'avait eue
et moi le premier je suis dit bon bah si
tu as survécu à un virus bien sûr pu
repartir et c'est une nouvelle vie qui
commence un peu la vida loca on va
pouvoir sortir mais finalement les
choses semblent un peu plus nuancé que
ça je pense que désormais les gens sont
très prudents et pour répondre à rené
pour michel cymes je me suis aussi
beaucoup trompé peut-être autant que lui
c'est juste que je n'ai pas la même
exposition et voilà on fait travailler
ce peut être un peu d'humilité j'ai ce
poids là je pense que maintenant on fait
un peu plus attention
jean-michel quelques questions et je
tendis que le chopper 2 fois c'est le
même qu'on a eus qui était endormie qui
se réveille on en chopent un de quelques
bonnes que l'on ne sait pas si on sait
pas si c'est une réactivation cette
hypothèse semble peu probable de la
réactivation comme de l'herpès vous
savez vous attraper une première fois
oui mais tu le connais des récurrences
fait des références coup si vous êtes
réinfectés par chien de garde et autant
pour l'instant on n'est sûr de rien il
va y avoir des études mais falloir
patienter sauf que le temps on en a pas
beaucoup